[Music]
good evening two kidnapping suspects are
off the streets tonight
we can also tell you more details about
that in just a moment but first it's
six o'clock and i'm denise valdez hi
denise i'm kirsten joyce
tonight two suspected kidnappers as you
mentioned are
in custody we learned hours ago that
49-year-old keith holman and 36-year-old
kristen phaf of perump
were arrested in henderson according to
the nye county sheriff's office the
victim
was held in a prompt building and was
rescued new year's day
let's head right over live to joe miller
joe mohler excuse me who has the very
latest joe
according to the night county sheriff's
office it was a tip from the public that
led to the arrest
here in henderson earlier today we spent
a lot of time in perum talking to people
who live in the area where this woman
was rescued and as you can imagine
people there were pretty shocked by this
story according to the sheriff's office
there the woman was held for months and
forced to do manual labor the victim was
allegedly kidnapped in march but of last
year and brought to the building you see
in this video with bar
windows and barricades at the front door
the building also has cameras and motion
sensors
police found out about her location
after her mother got a facebook message
from the victim according to authorities
neighbors in that area of pahrump were
shocked when they heard about what
happened
i couldn't believe it really it was hard
to believe
it just shows that that evil is
everywhere and you really need to keep
an eye on your neighbors and take care
of each other
this is not the first time this couple
has had a run-in with the law exactly
three years ago from today's arrest
there were
they were arrested in a case involving
starving animals the sheriff's office
reports keith holman sexually assaulted
the victim
in this case back in 2018. both are
facing a number of charges including
second degree kidnapping
and false imprisonment now this couple
is expected to be transported to the
night county detention center
reporting live in henderson this evening
joe mullen 8 news now